[Music]
welcome to this week's world stories how
a terrorist attack changed Istanbul
mining for gold in the Andes but first
to the US having completed his first
year in the White House President Donald
Trump is in an upbeat mood DW has been
out and about in Ohio
Mahoning Valley in Ohio a longtime
Democratic stronghold that was once a
half of the American steel industry but
these times are long gone
President Donald trum won Ohio in 2016
by promising to bring jobs back to the
region Tracie winbush believes in Trump
she hosts a talk show on local radio and
after she gets off the air she relaxes
in the cigar lounge he is earned my
respect because of what he wants to do
and how he wants to get it done so he's
not Republican he's not Democrat he's
just an American who used the system for
his advancement to the presidency and
you don't respect that I mean I'm but we
have to admit that he lies right it
doesn't tell the truth you have to admit
he has he has his own thought process of
his own truth but the question is do we
all lie also Tracy takes me along to a
party fundraiser in Youngstown the
latest polls show that president Trump's
approval rating is at a record low but
the people here support him despite the
fact that he hasn't made much progress
on his legislative agenda finally for
the first time maybe our lifetimes
there's somebody in Washington who is
determined to change Washington that's
why people are excited they want they
want someone to there Washington who can
grab that place and shake it because
it's become so bloated and so out of
control Christian mckernon is a
businessman in Youngstown his
grandfather started his heating and
cooling company in 1937 Christian says
he trusts Trump because he's also an
entrepreneur I don't have to agree with
certain things that a sitting president
may feel I don't have to but I really
should just look back in in respect to
position that's there and allow him to
tried to do his job online Tracy and
friends well good afternoon and welcome
to Tracy and Friends economic growth tax
cuts health care that's what counts for
Tracy winbush she says she doesn't like
everything Trump tweets or says but
she'll support him as long as he is here
to break the system it's just two years
since a suicide bomber blew himself up
in the heart of Istanbul's tourist
district
Sultanahmet 12 tourists and the bomber
were killed
correspondent Yulia Hahn went to see how
the attack has changed the city a selfie
in front of the world famous aya sofia a
memory shot next to the blue mosque the
Sultanahmet district is a must-see for
every tourist coming to Istanbul each
day visitors from all around the world
are crowding here and it was no
different on the 12th of January 2016
city guide TJ incasa Buber will never
forget that day she was there when a
suicide bomber blew himself up among a
group of German tourists he hadn't
called them yet I just stood there and a
lot of people started to run police and
ambulances came for a minute I thought
what should I do
Hazuki ho Sanna Sanna injured were taken
to the hospital I didn't know which
nationality they were so I went to the
hospital as well I thought I might be
able to hell with us
12 Germans were killed that January
morning the bomber died as well on the
same day the Turkish government set the
Islamic state group was behind the
attack the most visible change police
and armored vehicles are now everywhere
the number of security forces around
major touristic sites has increased
drastically
security analyst Ahmed Han says the
Sultan Ahmed attack was like a wake-up
call for Turkish authorities at the time
definitely the priorities were not set
properly this was a threat that was low
on the agenda and Turkish security
forces were not prioritizing it it has
been a wake-up call
definitely the security forces are now a
better prioritizing me collecting better
intelligence see acting much more
rigorously Charest extremists tourism
numbers have declined dramatically after
the attack the year 2016 has been a
catastrophe for Istanbul Sakana me but
now tourists are returning before we
came to Istanbul I was a little worried
but there are police around so I feel
safe we should worry about something
that happened two years ago with a crazy
guy so no go away you want to go do what
you want to do and don't be friends
city guide Tegan Casas Bova is showing
around a group of Chinese visitors in
Sultan Osman today she hopes she will
never have to witness an attack again
and wants to show tourists her city help
them find the best spots for a beautiful
memory shot
[Music]
clinging to an andean mountainside in
the south of ecuador the town of Sonoma
has long been famous for gold for
centuries miners have been busy digging
for the precious metal even directly
under the town itself Saruman Anna
Dillon gold mining town perched at an
altitude of 1,200 meters on the edge of
the Andes in southern Ecuador the old
town has been an Ecuadorian cultural
heritage site since 1990
zel Roma has a population of about
10,000 its architecture bears testimony
to the prosperity brought by 450 years
of gold mining but that prosperity is
under threat indeed some residents say
the town itself is in danger one of the
problems caused by mining this school
was 102 years old and then it suddenly
collapsed illegal and carelessly built
mines gradually encroached on the ground
the school was built on what the results
kind of it just sank we had to tear the
whole lot down because the danger is
imminent and we have to assume that
similar things will happen elsewhere in
the town one team was able to receive a
la serie the state granted mining
concessions without coordinating the
locations of the mines themselves
the result was practically a
free-for-all and one building after
another is collapsing the city hospital
has just been evacuated but collapsing
buildings are not the only problem in
seroma mining causes environmental
damage to the water released here flows
downhill and gets used by the local
population but the water down there is
contaminated with heavy metals such as
lead Chrome or radium Marco Galvez says
he wants to stains a rumor with his
family but for that to be possible he
says the town must change the way it
nature
they're getting ready in Star City near
Moscow ready to go into space for the
next mission to the International Space
Station this time the flight commander
is a German we have this report from our
Moscow studio these spacesuits aren't
for lightweights then tip the scales at
around 10 kilograms each once in space
is ensure that alexander gerst and his
crewmates sergei prokofiev and serena
and an Chancellor can survive in a
vacuum it will be the first time a garis
single serve as commander on the
international space station this is the
same space suit I wore when I landed
last time you can still see traces of
soot from my exit from the capsule I'm
one of the few lucky ones allowed to
train in my own space suit I'll get a
new one for the next flight it's
tailor-made for me and ready to go
this is the new Alexander Gerst had on
his first space flight in 2014 the
geophysicist became the third German to
fly to the International Space Station
during his next mission called horizons
the crew will conduct about 80
experiments some are new others guests
performed on his first flight
[Music]
the training center in the so called
star city near Moscow is steeped in
history generations of cosmonauts and
quite a few astronauts who were inducted
here the immediate future of space
research belongs to these three
astronauts to ensure their flight on the
6th of June goes smoothly they are doing
takeoff landing and docking exercises in
a reconstruction of the original Soyuz
space capsule the ground control staff
has installed some system failures to
simulate up to 12 breakdowns a day any
one of them could be fatal if undetected
and left unresolved that's why the
astronauts say this phase of the
training is the most difficult demanding
intense concentration and rapid decision
making capacity
we know what this involves more of a
risk than travelling by train but we're
not flying this mission just for fun
it's for scientific experiments we're
doing space research for the greater
good that's why I'm prepared to take
this higher risk vision who is equine
forty years after the first space flight
by a German Alexander Gerst will be the
first German commander on the
International Space Station the Horizons
mission will take off from the Baikonur
space launch facility in southern Gaza
Stan this summer
[Music]
you